don't you think people are going to be  looking at bitcoin as that ultimate  store of value like gold and therefore  not really want to spend it you don't  want to spend your bitcoin now because  you have fiat and so what happens is bad  money chases out good gresham's law and  so i want to spend my fiat save my  bitcoin but eventually on a bitcoin  standard we'll just save bitcoin spend  bitcoin et cetera and so it's an  evolution process that will get there  eventually but like i said it's old  thought old technology that we would  need two different systems because gold  was big heavy clunky it didn't make  sense but bitcoin can move at the speed  of light  and it can be the best savings so it can  be all in one show